قمه الايجاد تجمع وفدي الجيش والدعم سريع
اليوم واشنطن تدعو طرفي صراع لوقف فوري
للنار
يقول ان كيف لن تستهدف روسيا بالقنابل
العنقوديه
بالقديمه والفش
بعد انتقادات بايدن لحكومه اسرائيل وزير
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي يشن هجوما نابعا
على الرئيس الامريكي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى نشره الاهم الانباء من
العربيه تحتضر العاصمه الاثيوبيه اليوم
قمه ايجاد لبحث الازمه السوداني ويشارك في
القمه وفدان عن الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع اللذين دعتهما وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه في بيان لها الى انهاء القتال
على الفور والعوده الى
كما جددت الولايات المتحده ندائها لدول
المنطقه لمنع اي تدخل خارجي ودعم عسكري
مشيره الى ان ذلك لن يؤدي الا الى تكثيف
الصراع واطاله امته ياتي ذلك في الوقت
الذي اعلنت فيه الولايات المتحده زياره
مساعده وزير الخارجيه الامريكي للشؤون
الافريقيه الى اديس اباطا
مصادر العربيه ذكرت ان الرئيس الحالي
للاياده رئيس الجيبوتي اسماعيل عمر جيل لن
يحضر قمه الايجاد او الايجاد الرباعيه
المخصصه لبحث الوضع في السودان كما ذكرت
المصادر ان رئيس جنوب السودان سلفاكير لن
يحضر ايضا وسيرسل مستشاره هذا وكان الرئيس
الكيني ويليام روتو ورئيس وزراء اثيوبيا
احمد انهما سيلتزمان بالحضور وكان رئيس
ارتيريا قد وجه انتقادات للجنه ايجاد خلال
استقباله نائب رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
مؤكدا ان المبادرات المطروحه هي اشبه
بمزايدات سياسيه لا يمكن المشاركه فيها
وفي السودان اعلنت سلطه الطيران المدني
تمديد اغلاق المجال الجوي في البلاد حتى
نهايه الشهر الجاري باستثناء رحلات
المساعدات الانسانيه واغلق المجال الجوي
السوداني امام حركه الطيران بعد نشوب صراع
مسلح بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع في منتصف ابريل الباطل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
واحد
[تصفيق]
ذكر تقرير صحيفه
من القنابل العنقوديه الاوكرانيه وصفت
صحيفه نسبه الفشل في تلك القنابل
بالمرتفعه جدا وانها لا تنفجر فوريا بنسبه
14%
في الاثناء قال مستشار الامن القومي ان
اوكرانيا تعهدت بعدم استخدام تلك القنابل
في روسيا واستبعد سرفا في تصريح له حدوثا
انقسام في النيتو بسبب لقرار ارسال تلك
الذخائر لاوكرانيا
السفاره الروسيه في واشنطن دانت ارسال
القنابل العنقوديه الى اوكرانيا ورات فيها
اعترافا واضحا من الولايات المتحده
بارتكاب جرائم حرب في الصراع الروسي
الاوكراني
من جانبه دع الرئيس الالماني فرانك الى
عدم منع الولايات المتحده من تسليب قنابل
عنقوديه للجيش الاوكراني واشار شتان ماير
في بيان الله الى ان الموقف الالماني ما
زال مبررا واضحا انه ستكون نهايه اوكرانيا
ان لم يكن لديها وسائل للدفاع عن نفسها
ميدانيا اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه صد
هجمات اوكرانيه على محاور دوناتس وكراسي
الايمان وقالت الدفاع الروسيه في بيانها
اليومي ان الجيش دمر اليات عسكريه
اوكرانيه واسلحه غربيه خلال هذا الهجوم
خلال الفتره الاخيره اعتمدت اوكرانيا في
مواجهه سلاح الجو الروسي على صواريخ
ستينجر المضاده للطائرات غير ان الاستهلاك
الكبير لهذه الصواريخ من القوات
الاوكرانيه دفع بشركه راديو الامريكيه
المصنعه الى التحذير من صعوبه زياده
الانتاج
لم يغب هذا عن الذاكره يريد الاوكرانيون
وحلفاؤهم الغربيون لهذا المشهد ان يتكرر
ينتصر الافغان على السوفييت بدعم غربي قلب
موازين الحرب انذاك حينها برزت صواريخ
ستنجر الامريكيه
يتكرر السيناريو بتفاصيله بعد اربعه عقود
ويحضر في ساحه الحرب
سيره صاروخ تشير الى تدمير نحو 270 طائره
ومروحيه سوفيتيه في افغانستان في الحرب
الاوكرانيه اليوم حصلت كييف على المئات من
انظمه السنجر الامريكيه
تستنزف الحرب مخزونات الصواريخ بسرعه وهو
ما دفع بشركه رايفيون المصنعه الاستنجر ان
تحذر من صعوبه زياده انتاجه رئيس شركه
ريفون حذر العام الماضي من عدم قدره
الشركه على تسريع انتاج صواريخ السنجر
للعام الحالي ولعل هذا الركود ترجعه
الشركه الى عدم شراء البنتاجون وحدات ستين
منذ نحو 18 عاما اضافه الى عدم توفر بعض
المكونات تجاريا
والى ذلك الحين لا يعول الخبراء على
صواريخ ستنجر في تغيير مسار الحرب لكنها
تهدد المروحيه الروسيه وهو ما تحتاجه في
هجوم مضاد تواجه فيه القوات الاوكرانيه
عراقيل منها تفوق سلاح الجو الروسي
اظهر فيديو نشرته وكاله نكسه بيلاروسي على
تويتر التحولات في منطقه خزان سد ناخوفكا
بعد انخسار المياه نتيجه تدمير السد في
يونيو الماضي
ويرصد الفيديو الاثار الكارثيه حيث تظهر
الارض جافه في مكان الخزن
[موسيقى]
فيديو نشرته وكاله نيكستا اظهرت تحولات
الكارثيه بعد انحسار المياه في سد نوفا
كخوفك المدمر بعد ان كانت المناطق المحيطه
بالسد خضراء ويانعه تحولت لارض المتصحره
وجرداء سد نوفاك خوفكا دمر يونيو الماضي
متسببا بفيضانات ضخمه تداعيات انهياره ادت
الى اضرار على الزراعه وثروه الحيوانيه
وتسرب الزيوت الملوثه اضافه للقضاء على
الثروه السبكيه وتلوث المياه الجوفيه
ومياه النهر
وصل الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن الى لندن
حيث يعقد اجتماعا اليوم مع رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني ريش سوناك على ان يلتقي الملك
تشارلز الثالث لمناقشه تغير المناخ
المقرران يسافر بعد ذلك الى ليتوانيا
للمشاركه في قمه حلف الناتو غدا على ان
ينهي جولته في العاصمه الفنلنديه
قال البيت الابيض ان الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن عبر في مكالمه هاتفيه مع نظيره
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان عن رغبته في
الترحيب بالسويد عضوا في حلف شمال الاطلسي
في اقرب وقت ممكن واضاف البيت الابيض ان
رئيسي ناقش ايضا مجموعه من القضايا التي
سينظر فيها قاده حلف النيتو في القمه التي
تعقد هذا الاسبوع بما في ذلك دعم اوكرانيا
وبشان عضويه كيف فينيتو قالت وزيره
الخارجيه الفرنسيه كاترين كولانا ان
الضمانات الامنيه لاوكرانيا ستكون مسارا
موازيا ستكون مسارا موازيا وليس بديلا عن
ضمها
واعلنت الخارجيه الفرنسيه ان باريس ستقدم
حزمه مساعدات عسكريه جديده لاوكرانيا
قريبا واضافت انه يتم اعداد شحنات جديده
للمساعدات العسكريه لتلبيه الاحتياجات
الاوكرانيه الاكثر الحاحا وبينت الوزيره
الفرنسيه ان بلادها تريد ان توفر قمه
النيتو فيليوس فرصه لتعزيز دعم الحلف في
اوكرانيا على اساس طويل الامد ويعطائي
مضمون ملموس لاحتمالات انضمام اوكرانيا
الى
وبهذا الخصوص اكد الرئيس الاوكر انه لا
يريد الذهاب الى قمه النيتو من اجل
الترفيه متوقعا ان تتلقى اوكرانيا دعوه
للانضمام الى الحلف وضمرات امنيه حسب ما
اوردته صحيفه بوليتيكولا الامريكيه تابع
عزلانسكي ان دعوه من هذا النوع ستعد مؤشرا
على ان الناتو ليس خائفا من روسيا على حد
تعبيره ولذلك سيشكل رساله مهمه من الحلف
مضيفا بان اوكرانيا تعمل مع الشركاء بشان
ضمانات الامنيه وتود اتخاذ جميع القرارات
خلال هذه القمه
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن في مقابله
اجرتها معه شبكه سان ان اسرائيل والسعوديه
امامهما طريق طويل للتوصل الاتفاق لتطبيع
العلاقات بينهما يتضمن معاهده دفاعيه
مدنيا من الولايات المتحده قال بايدن اننا
ما زلنا بعيدين جدا عن ذلك ولدينا امور
كثيره نناقشها واشار الرئيس الامريكي الى
ان هناك تقدما يحرز في المنطقه وان هذا
يعتمد على التصرفات وما هو مطلوب منا
ليعترفوا باسرائيل على حد تصريحات الرئيس
الامريكي
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن قال ان الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الحاليه برئاسه بنيامين
نتنياهو هي الاكثر تطرفا منذ حكومه
جولداما انتقد بايدن خلال تصريحات لشبكه
سن ان خطط التعديلات القضائيه في اسرائيل
وكذلك بعض الوزراء في الحكومه بسبب ارائهم
بشان سياسه الاستيطان في الضفه الغربيه
وكذا ايضا ان حل الدولتين هو الخيار
الافضل بالنسبه للاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين
مشيرا الى وجود اتصالات مع الاسرائيليين
للتهديه كما حتى الرئيس الامريكي رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي على التهدئه واتخاذ
خطوات نحو الاعتدال والتغيير
الرد الاسرائيلي لم يتاخر وجاء على لسان
وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي اتمار بن
جفير الذي قال انه على بايدن ان يدرك ان
اسرائيل ليست جزءا من الولايات المتحده
ان يدرك اننا لسنا نجمه اضافيه في العالم
الامريكي لماذا يعتبرونني متطرفا هل هذا
بسبب اوامر لتوزيع اسلحه على الاسرائيليين
للدفاع عن انفسهم او دعم الكامل لشرطه
والجيش ادعو بايدن لزياره القدس والخليل
ليرى ان تطرفنا هو في حبنا لدوله اسرائيل
وعلى الارض فات مراسل العربيه بان القوات
الاسرائيليه اطلقت النار على فلسطينيه
واصابتها ثم اعتقلتها بزعب محاوله تنفيذها
عمليه طعن في القدس واوضح مراسل العربيه
ان موقع الحادث كان مقابل الشرطه اللوائيه
في القدس
اوجد احتجاجات جديده تشتاح المدن
الاسرائيليه رفضا لمشروع التعديلات
القضائيه وذلك للاسبوع السابع والعشرين
على التوالي حيث انطلقت احتجاجات معارضه
لخطه حكومه رئيس الوزراء باجراء تعديلات
قضائيه كما تعاهد قاده الاحزاب المعارضه
بتعزيز مظاهر الاحتجاج الى مستويات غير
مسبوقه يوم الثلاثاء القادم اذا تمرير
القراءه الاولى لمشروع القانون بالفعل
هذه النشره مستمره ولكن بعد فاصل قصير
اهلا بكم من جديد نظم العشرات من العاملين
في المرافق والمراكز الصحيه في محافظه
الحديده ومدينه الخوخه وقفه احتجاجيه
اعتراضا على تخفيض رواتبهم الى قلبنا
النصف وكذا المحتجون استمرار اضرابهم عن
العمل حتى الاستجابه لمطالبهم وسط مخاوف
من حدوث كارثه انسانيه بسبب الاضراب خرجنا
من اجل الغاء قرار تخفيض رواتب نعم اكثر
من خمسين في المئه
واعاده الراتب او الحافز
الذي استمرينا عليه منذ اربع سنوات حيث ان
الحافز الجديد
لا يكفي لمده عشره ايام وذلك بسبب التقاء
الغاء غلاء المعيشه والظروف الصعبه التي
تمر بها البلاد
ومنظمات وكل المنظمات اللي عامله
[موسيقى]
في الساحل الغربي في مسؤوليه تخفيض
الرواتب كمان ايذاء يعني
تمرن المراكز في التغليف
كيف الاوبئه الاوبئه منشوره في الخوخه معك
الملاريا مع كتافي التيفود معك
مشهوره طيب لما نتقفل المركز الصحي المريض
الجميع انه اذا تم انسحاب الكوادر الصحيه
من القطاع الصحي سوف يسبب كارثه انسانيه
كبيره
لذا نناشد كل القائمين وصلنا القرار بان
ينظر الينا بعين الانسانيه
ويجدوا لنا الحل منصف حيث نحن لا نتقاضى
سوى رواتب ضئيله جدا
نقلت وكاله رويترز عن منظمه
المهاجرين ان 300 مهاجر على الاقل مفقودون
في البحر بالقرب من جزر الكناري الاسبانيه
واشارت المنظمه الى ان الذين فقدوا كلهم
من السنغال وقد غادروا بلادهم بلادهم بسبب
عدم الاستقرار واوضح مصدر مسؤول في
المنظمه ان قاربين احدهما يحمل نحو 65
شخصا والاخر يحمل ما يقارب 60 شخصا
مفقودان منذ الخامس او منذ 15 يوما بعد
مغادرتهما السنغال في محاوله للوصول الى
اسبانيا وشار المصدر الى ان قاربا ثالثا
غادر السنغال في السابع والعشرين من يونيو
وكان على متنه نحو 200 شخص
قالت حكومه الوحده الليبيه ان ايطاليا
رفعت حضرا دام عشر سنوات على استخدام
الطيران المدني الليبي للمجال الجوي
الايطالي على ان تسانف رحلات الجويه
اعتبارا بسبتمبر المقبل
روما رفعت حضرا عن الطيران الليبي هذا
الحظر كان ساريا منذ عشر سنوات
بسبب الفوضى التي سادت في ليبيا بعد سقوط
النظام القذافي حيث تم تدمير مطار طرابلس
الدولي الرئيسي والاكبر في ليبيا
ليتم تسيير رحلات تجاريه عبر مطار عتيقه
الدولي المقام داخل قاعده جويه عسكريه
ويوجد حاليا عدد قليل من شركات الطيران
التي تسير رحلات جويه من والى ليبيا
القرار جاء عقب اجتماع بين مسؤولين من
البلدين وبعد فحص اجراءات السلامه في
المطارات الليبيه
لفتره طويله اقتصرت الرحلات الجويه من
ليبيا على دول عربيه وتركيا
اذ حضر الاتحاد الاوروبي على الطيران
المدني الليبي استخدام مجاله الجوي
سيتم تشغيل الرحلات بين ايطاليا وليبيا
بواسطه شركه طيران واحده من كل دوله
تعرض بالك باتا زاكربيرج لموجه انتقادات
بسبب اعدادات خصوصيه الاطفال على انستغرام
وذلك بعد نشره صوره يخفي فيها ملامح بنتيه
برموز تعبيريه ليصبح السؤال هل جوكر بيك
متيقظ بين اعدادات منصاته ستلاحق ايضا
اطفاله
انتقادات تلاحق المؤسسه التنفيذيه لمجموعه
ميته مارك زوكربيرج حينما نشر صوره في
الربع من يوليو يخفي فيها وجهي طفلتيه
خشيه استغلالها او استهدافها تصرفات توحي
للمستخدمين بان ذكر بيرج حريص على عدم
مشاركته موقع عائلته او حتى هويات اطفاله
اي بشكل او باخر فانه لا يثق بخوارزميات
منصاته فها هو يطمس وجوه بناته بالوجوه
التعبيريه ويتعمد نشر صورهن مره من الخلف
او بطريقه جانبيه لا تظهر فيها ملامحهن
كامله لكنه في المقابل يترك وجه الرضيعه
ملحوظا ما يعني ان الاطفال الرضع لا
يتعرضون للمخاطر ذاتها ووفق الخبراء فان
تكنولوجيا الذكاء الاصطناعي يمكن
استخدامها لتتبع تغيرات الوجه بمرور الوقت
وقد تظل قادره لاحقا على ربط ملامح الطفل
بصوره له عندما يكبر حال ذكر بيرج لا
يختلف كثيرا عن مشاهير وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي الذين ينشرون صورهم اليوميه
باستمرار ولكن اذا جاء الامر على اطفالهم
يستخدمون الرموز التعبيريه للمساعده في
حمايه خصوصيه ابنائهم
تشكل المعارض الثقافيه والمتاحف الاسلاميه
اضافه الى المواقع التاريخيه خيارات عده
لزوار المدينه المنوره حيث يقضون يومهم
يقضون يومهم وياخذون تجربه جديده خلال
زيارتهم الى المدينه الزميل عبد المحسن
الحربي والتفاصيل
اشراقه يوم جديد على الحجاج في المدينه
المنوره الحرم المدني وجهتهم الاولى في
الصباح للتامل والسكينه والتخطيط اليومهم
عليك
احب وقت الفجر عندما يختفي الظلام ويبزغ
النهار لانه يشعرني بالدفء والسعاده
وقت الفجر وقت تشعر فيه بالسكينه تشعر فيه
بالهدوء وكان بعد رحله الحج الذي فيها بعض
المتاعب والصعوبات من الوقوف على عرفه
ومزدلفه ومنها ورمي الجمرات تاتي الى
المدينه بعدها وكان احدا يحنو عليك مع
منتصف النهار تزداد حراره الشمس فيلجا
الحجاج الى زياره عشرات المتاحف والبعارض
يعود بهم متحف السيره النبويه الى الف
واربعمائه سنه من تاريخ الاسلام اشياء مثل
هذه المتاح مفيده جدا للاجيال الشابه
لاننا يجب ان نظهر لهم كيف كانت الامور في
الماضي انبس على جانب الحرم هنالك اماكن
مثل هذا المتحف الذي زرناه اليوم هذا
المتحف ليس مخصصا لموضوع واحد ويوضح اشياء
عديده حول الانبياء المختلفين
[موسيقى]
بحلول المساء يفضل الحجاج جاده قبى
الرابطه بين المسجد النبوي ومسجد قباء اول
مسجد في الاسلام ولا يخلو المسير من جوله
للتسوق عبد المحسن الحربي العربيه المدينه
المنوره
تسلم الممثل والمخرج قاسم اسطنبولي مؤسسه
المسرح الوطني اللبناني جائزه اليونسكو
الشارقه لثقافه العربيه بدورتها التاسعه
عشره وذلك في حفل رسمي اقيم بمقر منظمه
اليونسكو في باريس بحضور ممثلين عن دول
العالم وتعتبر الجائزه واحده من اهم
الجوائز الثقافيه الدوليه واختارت لجنه
التحكيم لاسطنبولي لمساهمته الرائده
والفريده في تفعيل الحركه الثقافيه في
لبنان وتنشيط الثقافه العربيه ونشرها في
العالم
[تصفيق]
هكذا رئيس الاتحاد الايراني لكره القدم
مهدي تاج بانه سيسمح للنساء الايرانيات
اللواتي منعنه قبل فتره طويله من حضور
مباريات كره القدم على نطاق واسع بالعوده
الى الملاعب خلال الموسم المقبل وذلك خلال
حديث مباشر في حفله سحب قرعه الموسم
المقبل للدوري الايراني الممتاز لكره
القدم ومن المقررات تبدا البطوله التي تضم
16 فريقا الشهر المقبل
وفي نهايه النشره هذا تذكير بابرز العرب
قمه تجمع وفضي الجيش والدعم السريع اليوم
واشنطن تدعو طرفي الصراع لوقف فوري للنار
سولفا يقول ان لن تستهدف روسيا بالقنابل
العنقوديه
بعد انتقادات بايدن لحكومه اسرائيل وزير
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي يشن هجوما لاذعا
على الرئيس الامريكي
المزيد بعد قليل على شاشه العربيه شكرا
لمتابعتكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات